We have two major areas of mental illness to cover, and those are personality
disorders and schizophrenia. So, let's start with personality disorders.
Personality disorders are another area where psychologists disagree, and their
classification in the DSM has been controversial. For example, some have
suggested that we look at these personality problems as extreme values on a
trait dimension such as the big five that we learned about in our lesson on
personality, and not call them a disorder. Approximately 15% of the general
population of people over the age of 18 have a personality disorder. But if you
look at the age range from 18 to 25, approximately 20% have a personality
disorder. Now let's go back to Lauren and learn a little bit more about this.